Trascrizione: Sara Pasini
Revisore: Luca Tomasi
Voi come lo immaginate uno Stato digitale?
Che aspetto dovrebbe avere?
Come dovrebbe funzionare?
Ecco, a queste domande normalmente
la risposta più immediata è
anche quella più intuitiva.
E purtroppo è una risposta sbagliata.
Intuitivamente tendiamo a immaginare lo
Stato digitale
così come immagineremmo
un qualsiasi prodotto o servizio digitale.
Un servizio digitale
o un prodotto digitale
rispondono fondamentalmente
a quattro caratteristiche.
Sono veloci, sono semplici, sono gratuiti
e sono tarati sulle esigenze degli utenti.
Un prodotto digitale
è veloce, velocissimo,
deve abbattere il tempo di latenza
che intercorre
tra il momento in cui voi date l’input
e il momento in cui
ricevete quel servizio.
Per cui, ad esempio, Uber vi
promette di entrare in contatto
con l’autista con un solo tap,
su WhatsApp potete ascoltare i messaggi
vocali al doppio della velocità,
su Amazon concludete una transazione
nel giro di 3 o 4 movimenti,
quindi pochi secondi.
Nel prodotto digitale di uso commerciale
il tempo non scorre consequenzialmente
come siamo abituati a immaginarlo,
ma si compone di tanti singoli
momenti e gratificazioni.
Pescando dalla mitologia greca diremmo
che nella tecnologia commerciale
Chronos, che era il tempo consequenziale,
abdica in favore di Kairos,
che invece era il tempo opportuno.
La seconda caratteristica del digitale
commerciale è la iper-semplicità.
Deve essere a prova di idiota,
meno sapete, meglio è.
Il BlackBerry, il telecomando, l’iPod e
il Walkman
sono tutti relitti
di un passato recentissimo,
ma oggi divenuto
desueto perché troppo complessi.
E se volete avere un esempio attuale di
ipersemplicità della tecnologia,
vi basta prendere il vostro smartphone
e guardarlo.
L’iPhone, ad esempio, viene venduto
senza manuale utente,
lo comprate, lo accendete
e lo utilizzate.
La terza caratteristica del digitale di
uso commerciale è la gratuità,
in realtà più percepita che reale.
Google Maps vi porta a destinazione
senza chiedervi alcun costo.
Tinder vi promette di incontrare l’anima
gemella senza farvi pagare.
Ogni minuto su YouTube vengono caricate
centinaia di ore di nuovi contenuti
e voi potete guardarli gratuitamente.
L’ultima caratteristica
del digitale commerciale
è il fatto di essere su misura per voi,
esattamente proprio per voi.
La cena che ieri sera avete ordinato su
Glovo, ad esempio, non era soltanto buona,
era quella più adatta alle vostre tasche
e ai vostri gusti di quel momento.
L’applicazione che vi dice
dov’è il parcheggio
non vi sta indicando
un parcheggio qualunque,
vi sta dicendo quello più vicino al
ristorante dove, per esempio,
questa sera andrete a mangiare.
L’algoritmo di Netflix sta per suggerirvi
il film che risponde più da vicino
ai vostri gusti.
Quindi vedete se noi andiamo a riprendere
la risposta che abbiamo dato poco fa
e applichiamo all’idea di Stato digitale
le caratteristiche che abbiamo
appena visto
e che sono proprie di un qualunque
prodotto o servizio commerciale,
dovremmo dire che un servizio pubblico
digitale è velocissimo, è iper semplice,
è gratuito ed è fatto su misura
di ciascun utente.
Ecco, questa è un'ipotesi irrealistica ed
è un errore tragico del modo in cui viene
concepito e raccontato lo Stato digitale.
Un errore tragico che si misura nel
divario che sussiste tra le aspettative
che ci dà la tecnologia di uso commerciale
e la realtà molto più deludente
che invece rappresenta
il servizio pubblico digitale.
Questo divario si misura in particolare
in tre elementi.
Il primo è quello della replicabilità.
Un servizio pubblico,
sia analogico che digitale,
deve necessariamente introdurre
delle complicazioni
che al settore privato non interessano.
Voglio farvi un esempio:
immaginate un soggetto fragile,
un soggetto in età pensionabile,
un soggetto ipovedente.
Ecco, costoro, se hanno un problema con
l’utilizzo dell’ultimo smartphone,
il problema purtroppo è soltanto loro.
Ma se costoro hanno un problema ad
accedere a un servizio pubblico
del comune di residenza, in quel caso
il problema è anche dello Stato.
Con questo vi sto dicendo che quando lo
Stato prova a digitalizzare un servizio
deve introdurre delle complicazioni che
sono normative e di design
per poter offrire un servizio inclusivo.
Uno stato digitale deve essere
necessariamente inclusivo.
Una tecnologia invece di uso commerciale
può essere esclusiva e spesso lo è.
Il secondo elemento che misura questo
errore dello Stato digitale
è quello della durabilità.
Lo Stato, le regole, le norme e le leggi
sono interamente basati
sul principio della durata.
Certo, esistono delle eccezioni.
Ma uno Stato che abdicasse all’idea
per cui le norme
che regolano il vivere sociale
debbono durare il più a lungo possibile,
sarebbe destinato al collasso, al caos.
Ora spostatevi nel mercato.
Vige il principio esattamente opposto.
Un'economia di mercato prospera
sul principio di obsolescenza.
Chi produrrebbe un prodotto
talmente efficiente
da non richiedere mai
di essere revisionato o sostituito?
Per cui siamo circondati, letteralmente
circondati da prodotti obsolescenti.
Il vestito all’ultima moda
che avete comprato oggi,
tra sei mesi sarà superato
da un nuovo catalogo.
Il computer di ultima generazione
che avete comprato questo mese,
tra meno di un anno non sarà più
quello che offre le
migliori prestazioni sul mercato.
Il terzo elemento che misura l’errore
dello Stato digitale riguarda la reazione.
Da consumatori, tendenzialmente,
se un prodotto non ci soddisfa, possiamo
spostarci verso un prodotto concorrente,
ma nello store civico,
da cittadini, dunque,
l’opt-out come lo chiamano gli inglesi
sostanzialmente ci è precluso.
E questo accade perché lo Stato il più
delle volte non opera in un regime
di concorrenza, per cui se un prodotto
digitale non ci piace lo cambiamo.
Se un servizio pubblico digitale non ci
piace, possiamo protestare,
ma non possiamo rivolgerci a un
soggetto concorrente.
Quindi, lo dico provocatoriamente, il
perimetro di garanzie che abbiamo
come consumatori rispetto al digitale,
per taluni aspetti è più ampio
rispetto a quello che abbiamo
come cittadini.
A questo punto, chiaramente la domanda è:
esiste un rimedio?
E l’ottimista vi dirà che sì,
il rimedio è la transizione digitale.
La transizione digitale lavora
esattamente a questo:
per rendere il servizio pubblico digitale
ancora più veloce,
sicuramente più semplice e gratuito,
sicuramente, e anche parametrato
sulle esigenze degli utenti.
Alec Ross recentemente ha detto:
“Digitalizzarsi o morire.”
E ci sono sicuramente ampi margini
di miglioramento.
Anche qui voglio darvi
qualche esempio.
Enel ha stimato che con i tempi attuali
necessari per ottenere
un’autorizzazione amministrativa
per gli impianti fotovoltaici,
all’Italia occorrerebbero 100 anni
per raggiungere i propri target
in materia di fotovoltaico.
La spesa al 2020 delle pubbliche
amministrazioni italiane
per la digitalizzazione dei servizi
pubblici era ferma al 19%.
Ci sono alcune cancellerie di tribunali
che obbligano i malcapitati avvocati
a stampare i documenti telematici,
a scansionarli nuovamente
e ad inviarli in pdf.
All’ottimista risponde il realista e dice:
“Attenzione, la transizione digitale
da sola non è in grado di colmare questo
divario, quindi non è in grado
di risolvere questo errore
dello Stato digitale.
Accanto al tavolo tecnico che abbiamo
appena visto
ce n’è un altro che è più importante
e che chiameremo tavolo culturale.
Il tavolo culturale consiste nel ridare
al servizio pubblico
la dimensione che gli è propria,
che è quella della complessità,
quella complessità che nel digitale
di uso commerciale
tendiamo a rifuggire, a scalzare.
Nel caso di un servizio pubblico
digitalizzato deve essere recuperata,
ed è una complessità che riguarda
tre aspetti;
le strutture, le procedure, e poi
soprattutto le persone.
La complessità delle strutture, anzitutto.
Una qualunque decisione pubblica
e dunque un servizio è il frutto
di una cooperazione
tra più amministrazioni su più livelli.
Pensate al certificato verde digitale che
avete mostrato per entrare qui oggi.
È il risultato di una collaborazione
che parte dalla Commissione europea
e coinvolge i governi nazionali, coinvolge
le amministrazioni territoriali,
nel nostro caso quelle regionali,
e in molti casi anche dei soggetti privati
che si sono occupati di alcuni aspetti
di implementazione tecnica.
E questa catena richiede tempo,
è una catena complessa.
C’è poi una complessità delle procedure.
Una procedura, una decisione,
è il frutto dell’incontro,
del bilanciamento tra interessi
che sono tra loro divergenti,
che devono essere discussi,
negoziati e bilanciati
all'interno di una decisione finale.
E questo bilanciamento richiede tempo.
Tempo fa, un noto professore di economia e
al tempo ministro dell’Economia,
disse una frase celebre:
“Le tasse sono bellissime.”
Ecco, parafrasando, potremmo dire che
la complessità delle procedure,
fintanto che è necessaria per tutelare
i diritti di noi tutti, è bellissima.
E poi l'ultimo elemento, la
complessità delle persone.
Anche qui voglio darvi qualche
informazione, qualche dato.
C’è un miliardo di persone nel mondo
che è privo di identità,
compresa l’identità digitale,
che è la chiave per accedere
ai servizi pubblici in formato digitale.
Se poi guardiamo alle competenze che molti
degli studenti universitari oggi
apprendono sui banchi, bene quelle stesse
competenze e quelle conoscenze
nel giro dei prossimi 4 o 6 anni
diventeranno obsolete e fuori mercato.
Addirittura le competenze digitali,
si stima che una su tre ogni anno
non sia più necessaria.
Il punto della complessità delle persone
all'interno del servizio digitale
consiste in questo;
abbiamo da una parte le tecnologie
che cambiano il modo di
produzione dei beni.
Stiamo passando verso una maggiore
attenzione a beni intangibili.
I dati, ad esempio. E dall’altra parte
cambiano completamente il modo
in cui le prestazioni lavorative
devono essere erogate,
per cui coloro che lavorano,
coloro che lavoreranno un domani,
si trovano soggetti a due forze,
pressioni contrapposte.
Una riguarda il modo in cui essere
preparati e competitivi
sul mercato delle professioni e l’altra
riguarda il modo in cui dovranno erogare
la prestazione professionale.
Questo, per una struttura pubblica,
significa fondamentalmente tre cose.
Ripensare completamente chi vogliamo
all’interno delle pubbliche
amministrazioni,
che oggi sono sovrappopolate
da giuristi come me
e invece non hanno sufficienti competenze
STEM, ad esempio,
quindi le competenze tecniche.
Secondo, ripensare
e re-ingegnerizzare completamente
il modo in cui noi attribuiamo
le competenze
E terzo,
ripensare il modo in cui i servizi
pubblici digitali vengono erogati.
Ecco, arrivando alla conclusione.
Lo Stato digitale oggi sta combattendo
una sfida per uscire dal’errore tragico di
narrazione
in cui lo abbiamo ingabbiato
fino ad oggi.
Questa sfida si gioca su due tavoli,
uno è quello tecnico.
L’altro, più importante, è il tavolo
culturale della complessità e occorre
recuperare al servizio pubblico digitale
e raccontarlo nella sua dimensione di
complessità delle strutture, delle
procedure e soprattutto del fattore umano.